hello uh everyone can hear me so this is
going to be a difficult talk not for you
but for me because in 30 minutes I have
to explain to you the basics and all the
weirdness about quantum computing and
then also motivate you as data
scientists to take this field in a more
serious way and really try to see what's
going on in this area so I wanted to
make a meme but then I was not sure if
the euro meme band stuff is going to
lend me in trouble but nevertheless just
before I tried to make this thing so if
you have watched ant-man and the wasp
there's a scene where the the main guy
ant-man he says do you guys just put the
quantum world everywhere like he was
completely like you know boggled by all
this quantum realm quantum tunneling
quantum this quantum that and in real
life it feels like this every other day
you have a news article saying Oh Google
made a 72 qubit quantum processor it's
gonna change everything drug discovery
chemistry machine learning and so and so
on I mean there this idea recurring idea
of using quantum mechanics as something
which is all powerful computing device
or technology but the actual the actual
science and the actual technology that
we have is actually pretty limited but
then you still have all these areas
where you can see some kind of quantum
effects being used to develop a new
technology you have like the big
government organizations like the U
quantum flagship initiative to make a
quantum computer qtek you have all the
big companies and even you have smaller
companies collaborating with research
institutions to build quantum devices of
course the new cycle creates the hype
and you have every other day articles
which says Oh big data is going to be
completely changed by quantum mechanics
you have all these articles even at ICL
art this year this this article was
pretty interesting and then you have the
other side of it which is AI controlling
quantum computers and so and so on so as
I said it's a two-way street there are
two things that can happen here one is
quantum computing information can really
revolutionize
optimization machine learning and AI and
these are some of the references that
you can look and this is also
chronological I think where the whole
idea seems to feel like okay it start
from here and then someone realize you
can also do this and that and so and so
on but of course all of these have some
caveats and limitations I will speak
about it then you have the other
approach which is a adiabatic quantum
computation which is a bit of an
analogue approach and specifically
geared towards solving optimization
problems or finding the minimize energy
landscape then there's also hardware
approaches where you are you want to
make a synapse with some kind of quantum
device for example nanophotonics
circuits and the advantage of these kind
of circuits are they're extremely energy
efficient it's a bunch of mirrors which
is your neural network and once you
shine light through it to basically get
inference with no energy costs you also
have something which is with with these
superconducting circuits and people were
able to show that these circuits are
even faster than how the neuron computes
in your brain and of course they're
energy efficient so you have these kind
of different things that's going on in
this quantum AI machine learning merger
then you have the opposite thing where
you have machine learning helping people
in quantum physics one of the most
important and sort of exciting things
for me would be designing and
controlling quantum experiments so ten
years back an experiment which fetched
the Nobel Prize which is finding a
really unique state of matter
bose-einstein condensates you can do it
with a reinforcement learning Prince
algorithm now you give the control of
your lasers to to AI to a reinforcement
learning algorithm and tell it oh I want
to create this state and it will
precisely fire these lasers so that it
can trap you know matter in a completely
new phase and this can be done in a in a
matter of hours where an experimentalist
would take hours or days to just
calibrate the instrument so this is
quite exciting then also in quantum
mechanics you have problems which which
have an increasing amount of data and
then you can use neural networks as sort
of hypotheses or answers to
solve this kind of problems and you have
this really good paper on solving
many-body problems with this neural
network quantum states and this is
interesting because you need complex
numbers to describe these neurons and
most of the approaches by Torche tensor
flows they have difficulty or nobody
even cares about complex numbers outside
quantum mechanics but they showed that
with this answered you can really solve
many body quantum physics problems very
efficiently better than the models
physicists have come up with and then
finally this is very very recent which
is quantum inspired algorithms so a data
scientist who works at the bridge
between these two fields once realizes
oh this this weird quirky effect of
quantum mechanics I can just mimic it in
a classical algorithm and tries to write
some code and we see that this is
eighteen year old guy even Tang from MIT
I think yeah he made a recommendation
algorithm which is exponentially faster
just by looking at what the quantum
counter part of it was doing and is like
oh but this I can mimic in a classical
system hard-coded and boom you have a
exponentially faster classical algorithm
for this problem so why are we thinking
about this right now there are several
important points here but two of them
are the most important so we have 40
nanometer chips now which is 50 atoms
apart Apple I think the iPad pro has
seven nanometer chips which would be
like and very soon if you want to reach
a limit where you have single atom apart
devices you're going to run into weird
quantum effects which will render your
circuits you useless for example the
notion of a barrier in a gate in a chip
is gone here because you have something
called quantum tunneling where even
though you you make a wall and you want
to prevent things from going from here
to there there is a probability given by
a quantum tunneling effect that they'll
just mysteriously appear on the other
side so all your electronics would not
work at this scale so you have to think
about quantum mechanics of course you
have thermodynamic limits where your
circuit might just burn by the heat
produced just to manipulate information
at that level and then of course there
are the other reasons that somehow
quantum mechanics seems to give you an
exponential
advantage in tackling big data and you
can solve problems in machine learning
so bit versus qubit we all know bits
zeros and ones qubits is the quantum
equivalent of it where you no longer
have a zero or one but you have like a
superposition
but why Why should there be a
superposition of things why not just
single one or zero that's because in
quantum mechanics reality your reality
is always described in terms of a
probability wave function I'll get to
this in the next slide why should things
have this this probability wave nature
so it turns out if you do an experiment
with electrons which we know are solid
lumps of let's say billiard balls or
something and the experiment goes like
this you have two holes or two slits
where your electrons can pass through
and you keep shooting electrons through
these two holes you expect that because
you just have two holes there should be
just two lines out there but the
electron never behaves like this the
electron gives something which is called
an interference pattern alternate light
and dark bands so scientists were like
why why is this electron which we know
is a solid lump behaving in a very weird
way and this same behavior can be
completely explained if you consider a
wave passing through you would have seen
two waves when they are at the same
place at the same time they cancel each
other or raise each other's amplitudes
and so there was a crazy proposal by all
the physicists starting off the last
century that okay let's say the reality
of these objects are somehow defined by
the probability and this probability
behaves in a sort of wave and so because
of this crazy idea they were able to
explain this experiment and a lot of
other experiments so here is just a
small animation which shows okay if you
have two different possibilities and you
put them together somehow they can exist
simultaneously as raising a lowering of
amplitude but then again it's a crazy
notion to have ones and zeroes are both
ones and zeroes simultaneously but
there's a thing that is saying called
shut up and calculate because this is so
good this this model of reality
physicists nowadays are like okay the
math works it gives us the result shut
up and calculate so this is one school
of thought which is like okay we just go
with the results that it gives me and it
is one of the most successful theories
that we have come across as humans
because it hasn't failed yet in any of
the predictions that it made however
crazy it be so then you would think oh
if I can have superposition of things I
can it's limitless exponential speed-up
over things like if you have three
qubits which can simultaneously be one
or zero so if you have three qubits
there are eight possibilities and now
you have a superposition of all of them
so you have some sort of massive
parallelization but hearing where nature
kicks you in the in the shin basically
tells you a but you can't do that
because you have something which is
called the measurement problem because
the moment you look or you want to find
out what is going on
nature immediately hides all the
quantumness and gives you just one
result take it it's a zero or a one you
never have some the notion of
superposition in the results so this is
called the measurement problem and it's
a very tricky thing if you have let's
say a superposition of these as a
quantum state you can never basically
recover these coefficients you can never
know what what are these coefficients
what do you do is once you measure you
get either this or this or this and you
have to reconstruct these probabilities
from the statistics so nature just
reveals you the statistics and you have
to do it again and again and again and
then you find you know what the result
is then someone might say oh but let's
say I have a superposition I apply a
function to it it happens finally all
possibilities and then once I get the
result I make many clones of it and I
measure each of these clones and I say
Oh 90% of the times it's this is this
guy so answer should be this guy but
again nature kicks you here and says no
you cannot do something which is cloning
a quantum state and there's a theorem
for it I wouldn't go how to explain how
it happens but basically the moment you
try to find information about your
system nature just puts you in one of
the possibilities instead of the
superposition so this is how like
confesses try to write
them so that at the end of it the the
final result that you get has a high
probability of finding the answer but
you're never sure that you will get the
answer 100% so it's sort of similar to
probabilistic computing this is a
another very interesting experiment to
show how measurement changes your
reality if you take light which I want
to say what's polarization but let's say
you have light which can oscillate in
all directions you put a filter Polaroid
filter lets you orient it towards zero
you only let light pass which is
oriented or oscillating in this
direction
you put a 90 degree filter and you know
that you are not going to see any light
because it's only going this way and
it's gonna block the path but what's
interesting is if you now put a
45-degree filter in the middle so you
have zeros you have 90 and you have
nothing passing by but the moment you
put a 45-degree filter here suddenly you
have some output in in this in the in
the end which is crazy because you see
the the only difference between these
two experiments is putting this
45-degree filter so somehow this
45-degree thing is recreating the
oscillations in the in the vertical
direction how does this happen
and this happens because the moment you
measure something you sort of not only
just see what the output is but you
effect it and completely change its
state and one of the ways to explain it
is basically when you have this guy as
zero
it connects it is in some sense
mathematically a superposition of this
this 45 degree guys and then when you
have a 45 degree filter of course it can
let this thing pass and now this thing
when it's measured it can again have two
components like this so it's some
counterintuitive logic but this works
and again we do shut up and calculate so
okay another extremely weird feature is
called entanglement where two things
seemingly separate on the other sides of
the universe somehow share a link
together
there are several incorrect notions
about entanglement and I will try to
break some of the things but the basic
idea is you take two particles make them
interact somehow put
in two corners of the universe ends now
if this person Alice let's say and this
person Bob decide to measure some
property of their system it immediately
shows some correlation so if this is a
one this will always be a zero or if
this is a zero this will always be a
zero and the weird part is it's not
something like you have a box and you
have a red ball and a blue ball and you
separate them and you know that it's
going to be a red or blue there's no
magic in there but the weirdness here
comes is if they decide to measure some
other property not just up and down but
let's say left and right they see
correlations in the same thing so it's
not a matter of pre-selecting what
you're going to do it's a matter of
right at this moment I decide to look if
it's up or down and I ask Oh Alice what
did you see and she sees down and then I
say okay let's measure left and right
and I see left and she will see a right
so somehow the act of me looking into my
quantum state is called collapsing the
state that Alice will get it is a
completely weird phenomena which is
called quantum entanglement and this is
actually one of the key factors why
quantum computing sort of can give some
advantages but of course this is this
does not mean faster-than-light
communication because of two reasons one
is you cannot use this thing as it as a
telephone you cannot do like oh now I'm
gonna make this down and Alice will see
it up no the only power that you have is
just looking what it is and the moment
you look it you kill the entanglement
you collapse your system to a down and
Alice's system is up and you cannot do
some kind of signaling with this then
someone might say oh but then you still
already do the signaling because if she
has a down and you have a up you have
some information exchanged but this is
not faster than light because at the
beginning both of you decide which
direction you want to measure if you
don't decide that and then try to do
measurement left right you'll only get
random results so it's kind of tricky
and nature is not so kind to us to use
this awesome effects yeah this is just
the joke about how the Bell's Theorem
basically is a very nice theorem where
you can show
this kind of correlations in numbers and
this is just a joke that okay
misunderstandings of Bell's Theorem or
let's say quantum entanglement happens
so fast that they would violate locality
or it's faster than light so what can we
do with all that quantum the first idea
was basically to simulate quantum
physics because if you just want to
simulate how two electrons talk to each
other how a hydrogen atom behaves as you
make your system slightly complex the
amount of data that it generates is
impossible for a computer to handle it's
it's exponential so the first idea is oh
if we have a toy quantum system and we
want to measure some properties we have
to build a quantum computer then we have
some very nice problems in computer
science and mathematics factorization is
one of it where it was shown that a
quantum computer can achieve some
exponential advantage recently you have
optimization and machine learning which
comes into this picture and people are
trying to use quantum algorithms for
optimization and machine learning I'll
come to that in the next slides then you
have quantum chemistry which is one of
the most promising avenues for this
because if you want to make a drug and
you don't know how it reacts to a slight
change in maybe potential energy and you
can't calculate it or simulated in a
normal computer you need to have a
device which works in a quantum way and
then of course quantum pattern
recognition because you have this kind
of quantum systems and there are some
patterns but if these patterns are as a
result of quantum phenomena can you even
describe it in terms of classical
physics mathematics or with all your
algorithms so because it's a Python
conference let me give you a hands-on
experience with some quantum circuits
one of the circuit is just not gate so
you take a zero it flips it to one but
if you take a superposition of zero and
one now this not gate can flip it to a
superposition of zero and one and it
flips the probability so this alpha and
beta are sort of the probabilities of
getting a zero or one then you have
something which is a Hadamard gate which
is a truly random gate you feel it as
zero and it makes a nature guaranteed
random number generator where it will
always give you a possibility of 50
zero 50% one but what if now you are
okay the next thing is a is a two cubed
kit which is basically controlled not so
if the first qubit says one only then
the naught is applied to the second if
the first qubits is 0 the naught is not
applied to the second one and this is
interesting because this is an tangling
gate this is the if-else in a normal
computer of course you can write this as
if if first qubit is 1 second qubit is 0
and so and so on but this if else is now
here guaranteed to you by nature by by
quantum mechanics you don't have to
write any false and you can quickly see
that if you if you parallel a I mean if
you write it for a large enough qubit
state let's say 50 or 70 you know bit
strings you have to do so many if-else
conditions but then if you have a
quantum computer which applies the
circuit you just feed the superposition
and it gives you a superposition as a
result but again you have the
measurement problem so you cannot expect
to you know get the answer for every
computation in one shot you have to
measure and then you get the answer for
just maybe one of the conditions let's
say you want to solve a Sat problem
satisfiability you enter a string and
you ask o does this formula satisfy this
string and if it's a 1 it satisfies and
you have a solution now if you make a
superposition of every single
possibility that you can throw at it and
throw it at this computer it evaluates
of course parallely because of this
quantum superposition but in the end the
result is just a 0 or 1 which says
sometimes it does sometimes it doesn't
and of course it will be more number of
times that it doesn't satisfy if you are
really lucky in that one random shot you
will get the answer which is correct so
of course the measurement problem is one
of the biggest problems here so one of
the example is the quantum die basically
you just take three qubits put three
hard gates which randomize your qubits
and you get a sampler basically which
gives you 0 0 0 0 0 1 with the
probability 1 over 8 so if you want to
use some tool there are a lot of Python
tools to do this this is a company
called Righetti they have this spike
equal software
just writing any other Python software
you import your your program you import
your cubits you import your functions to
apply on these cubits you do you run
your circuit and then you do something
like simulate measurement where it
probabilistically gives you one of the
answers at the same thing is developed
by project Q it is Uruk and it's similar
you apply you want to take three cubits
you allocate it to your engine you apply
some gates to it and you measure the
cubits and then you flush out and print
what's the result of measurement
there's IBM Q where they just go to
drag-and-drop cubits and gates and stuff
like that so open sources plays playing
a big role in this whole area so these
are some of the open source tools that
came up and you can see everything right
now is bison bison bison like most of
the interfacing is done with Python now
I would like to mention q-tip which is
more to do quantum mechanics than
quantum circuits and it's extremely
successful package which 600 academic
citations so here now I would like to I
have eight minutes to describe something
maybe which is very relevant to data
science local minima the problem of
local minima there are quantum
algorithms we which try to solve this
problem and one of the algorithms is
adiabatic quantum computing or annealing
what you do is let's say this this this
audience is some sort of particles who
are interacting with you with each other
let's say this person doesn't like this
person so you wouldn't want to stay near
this person if you stay near this person
you're angry irritated you you heat up
and your energy of the system increases
you can think of this as a system of
quantum particles where maybe these two
people don't like to stage other or the
SU particle shouldn't be near the energy
of the system gets high maybe these two
like to be near each other and the
energy of the system goes down so what
what people did was they took a
optimization problem and mapped it on to
a system of spins and now just by
cooling down or pumping energy out of
the system you're trying to make these
qubits or these spin systems get into a
configuration which gives you the best
possible
minimum and here is like a classical
simulation of this adiabatic approach
where instead of just going downhill on
a gradient platform you say okay I make
a jump and there's a probability that I
will make that jump or not doesn't
matter if it raises the energy or lowers
this energy this probability is
temperature in physics and you start
with the large margin so that your
system can run and explore everything
and slowly slowly you anneal it or you
reduce this probability of the jump and
somehow heuristic aliy this gives you an
answer the quantum version of it has a
peculiar effect which is this quantum
tunneling so that if you have a very
high barrier and you're doing random
jumps and you're not able to get out of
this barrier if this width is small you
can just tunnel through and this is one
of the really interesting phenomena how
the whole difference between simulated
or classical and healing and adiabatic
approaches different from the quantum
approach then you have quantum inspired
algorithms of course which I talked
about before you have a m cross n matrix
of recommendation and people and
recommendations and you want to just
complete one of the rows of this matrix
if you know something like you know some
of the things the person likes and then
you would like to predict something else
classic recommendation problem so even
thank he he started to find a proof that
the quantum algorithm is exponentially
sorry a classical algorithm cannot be
found which is exponentially better than
the current one and he couldn't instead
he ended up devising or finding a
classical algorithm which is
exponentially fast and matches with this
current descent Prakash quantum
algorithm so all the quantum advantage
killed in one shot then you have another
example where people now want to
preserve and say oh but quantum is
better we can do something with quantum
that we cannot do it classical so the
design experiments experiments are
problems in quantum physics which are
called this frustrated spin problems
similar you put these two objects
together near you and they're frustrated
because they don't want to stain here
and then you can show that by
constructing these problems
are defining them in a quantum
mechanical way the quantum algorithm
will perform of course better to solve
this but the classical won't but then
here there is a very interesting thing
and this is 2018 the start of 2018 is
that if someone just mimics the quantum
behavior this quantum tunneling then
both of these algorithms come to the
same level so it's not just you know the
quantumness which is doing it it's the
idea that okay this thing can happen in
nature which would never think of like
how do you think of penetrating you know
a solid wall in an energy landscape
you'd not think of it but then quantum
mechanics does this and if you hard-code
this in your code somehow you can you
know get an exponential advantage but of
course we are just simulating this I
mean think about this as writing a code
on your computer to say Oh
instead of making a jump here jump to
the energy surface but the quantum
computer would actually do it so in some
sense people are thinking oh then it's
probably better to do it with a real
quantum computer perfect this brings me
to the end of this talk so these are
exciting times ahead for both
communities because on one side your
physics quantum computing quantum
information researchers who are
discovering this area of data science
neural networks deep learning and on the
other side you have quantum data
scientists who are now seeing okay what
can we do with these quantum algorithms
so I believe that maybe a bunch of
quantum aware data scientists can really
help push this research forward also in
collaboration with the physicists there
are hardware challenges we don't have a
quantum Ram we don't know that if you
give me a big vector a classical vector
maybe an image how do I load it in my
quantum system and randomly access it at
each point because I don't we don't know
how to make a efficient a good quantum
ram there are problems with error
correction because quantum mechanics
doesn't allow you to look when you are
performing the experiment the moment you
look you kill the quantumness
so how do you correct for errors if
something goes wrong so and machine
learning is playing a big role here
because somehow these machine learning
algorithms are sort of able to sniff out
this error correct them by themselves
and so and so on proving definitive
quantum advantage like there are some
which are proven to be really good
really efficient fast but as you as I
discussed here there are many times
where people haven't just looked
carefully into the advantage and just by
looking carefully and mimicking maybe
some of the behavior of quantum Ness you
can just destroy the the advantage that
you have quantum mechanically and of
course the last most interesting thing
would be quantum pattern recognition so
if you have a quantum system what kind
of patterns can emerge and how can you
use the tools that we have now to
recognize those kind of patterns so
thank you if you want to get the slides
contact me or something this is a
website I have a website and I will take
questions now thank you for interesting
presentation and one quick question
could you briefly elaborate more on
think you said at the end about how the
machine learning algorithms can sniff
into quantum computers and quantum
computations okay so this this error
correction problem is basically if you
have a very large quantum state you have
many many parameters associated with the
probabilities is that a 1 is it a 0 or
is it a 1 0 1 1 0 0 so now if you really
want to identify this state and correct
it you would need something like you
need to know exactly all these variables
and parameters and stuff what people are
trying to find out and have seen is that
if you just gives me some partial
information about my state maybe not the
complete information measure some of it
collapse some of it these algorithms
neural neural networks or other machine
learning approaches are able to somehow
find some implicit way to connect this
partial data to the error that would
have possibly caused it which is not
completely clear
to design by yourself so somehow you
just it's it again becomes like a big
data problem you just give it a lot of
data and somehow it sniffs out by some
partial methods that okay this is the
error that would have caused it so I'm
just gonna apply this and invert this
error and so and so on so I'm not
completely an expert on this but this
you could read one of the references
probably I got a question about the
optimization ugh you you've talked about
the tunneling effect can you explain how
is it different from for example if in a
genetic algorithm you have a random just
random change like a mutation so one of
the things is we already have this
random effect which is stochastic jumps
or some thermal effects so this this
tunneling is sort of like let's say if
you have if you if you're stuck at
something here which is like very sharp
and small and if you try to do this
random jumps maybe you just keep getting
stuck and getting back at it but if you
have this tunneling then you basically
tunnel through and go to the next value
so sort of different button again these
kind of effects people are now just
discovering both the sides so it could
as well be like a different
manifestation of the same technique in
classical systems okay so thank you very
much again some applause for speaker
thank you very much
[Applause]